so first thing I wanted to ask you I'm a
huge horror fan there isn't all that
much horror on your resume so what was
it about the genre elements of dr. sleep
that really spoke to you and made this
project a must well it's not really
about the genre for me I don't I don't
it's not part of my decision-making
really you know I don't I don't think oh
I should do a horror film cuz I'm done
one I just was fascinated by the
character and the idea of its being an
follow-on story from The Shining
so piqued my interest and III think I
would have been skeptical about it had
it been somebody unrelated just writing
that our sequel version to The Shining
it would have been more skeptical about
but once I found out that Stephen King
had written a novel in 2014 called dr.
sleep that was a follow-on novel from
The Shining I thought oh no okay that's
interesting let's I was interested to
read the script and then I met Mike
Flanagan who I just really had a
unusually deep meeting with for the
first time I met directors all my life
and I went to meet him and his edit
suite of haunting of Hill House that he
was he was physically editing that TV
show and we sat down and just in two
hours we just had talked a lot about our
lives and a little bit about the film in
the character but mainly about I was
just very open with him and I came away
feeling like there's somebody that I
could trust and if if I wanted to
explore the themes of this movie and
what Stephen was writing about with you
know sobriety and recovery things that
have got strong power in my own life
then I wouldn't want to do it with
somebody like this so it was that really
more and more than the you know I was
curious a little of what it was like
working with Mike particularly as a
director with an editorial background as
an actor's director can you tell the
difference in that area of his work it's
very telling he's thinks like an editor
I mean he thinks in shots in a way that
most
rector's well every direct is different
that's the truth there's no there is no
normal or usual way about it everybody
is very unique but he thinks like an
editor so and he works very quickly
frustratingly quickly sometimes in terms
of he'll will do one take and he'll go
okay we've got it when you move on I now
say well how can we do another take and
he goes no I only need it for this bit
and I got you we got that bit so he's
thinks in a different way you know I
think for the actors you you want to
perfect every take from beginning to end
and you want to have a few goes at it
and but he but it was more it was more
you could tell you were being directed
by somebody who came at it from from
editing for sure very very important in
some of these sequences that I'm not
gonna spoil yet yeah I also wanted to
ask you about balancing Kubrick's
interpretation of the story with Stephen
King's I know that was on Mike shoulders
oh yes but did you have that in mind at
all when you were approaching bringing I
worried about it before we started
shooting because I thought that's that's
where we could that's that that is the
hurdle that Mike had to come get over
was the fact that there are two there
are the people who love the novel and
there are people who love Kubrick's
movie and they're not necessarily in
each other they don't cross over a lot
because Kubrick made a lot of changes to
the story that Stephen King didn't like
and and I think a lot of fans of the
novel felt like didn't you know weren't
happy with that so I worried that well
we're it's gonna be seen to be in the
follow-on movie from The Shining how are
we going to please everybody go but he
managed to do it beautifully Mike with
our fourth act he did something very
very clever
and at the end of our movie which sort
of gives the fans of Stephen King's
novel who were aggrieved by Kubrick's
movie he sort of gives them he gives
them what they were missing I couldn't
agree more clever isn't it I'm gonna
switch gears and go to spoilers so you
gotta wait for that until you see dr.
sleep then come back to this interview